moi j'ai beaucoup donné dans les années
soixante toiles se dérouler vendredi la
compagnie trois ilets en caoutchouc au
quartier dans sa lente remontée l'école
galusha nous avons partagé la fête bus
pour monter les colas était sorti à
boire le vin de gauchy maire et après
monter les cols alors ça a duré jusqu'à
15 ans parce qu'après caisse dans le mot
coin les wolfies des bamakois wasquehal
pas moins bon sans difficulté pour
pouvoir aller plus loin parce que c'est
une aubaine appelle l'agent nous battre
à petit problème allait être à chercher
travail me trouvais travail est temps
que mme annette masson alors mon fer
l'amazone et les blés mûrs du jeu colle
pendant 20 ans et après le véto la
maçonnerie la 9ine tous les mois dans la
savane des esclaves on va dire comment
se faire un peu marcher mais de matières
vu faire baisser le service mon temps
car b et du couvert paille
alors pour moi la marque et recouvre un
chaos et après la campagne j'ai en fait
le jardin puis en tomates les sites
d'arrêt est monté pour vider normal moi
commenté prévu je crois pas nier aux et
puis alan jadin savoir qui est le seul
service localisé mais pas encore
effectivement team était payant les
marchés à s'affaisser mineurs comme
mario comme abba you à l'homme a dit bob
casey formait autour de ce à quoi à
l'hormadi donc à réaliser un village
après l'esclavagé quoi l'évolution voire
mais les mouvements illégaux moment nous
parions que mon niveau des boyaux corio
100 magasins sans pharmacie sans que ces
bêtes al-alam avait dit qu'à monter des
tic est identique et puis s'arrêter ni
les motifs beatty et tout sa vie n'est
pas un long l'ampleur quoi c'est passe à
la télé comme moi ces soutiens dans les
différents magazines et l'amour mon
commencé dit gilbert c'est un booking
fees mais ses avocats intéressés un seul
mandat veut dire âprement pour un
bouquet foulée monte vraiment commencé
ça tu habites il à moi c'est benoît
vraiment intéressés par la vie à bord de
cavage larmandier ils seront la gamme en
bourse
la forme était comme au combat pour
rajouter partie esclavage qua non pour
moi projets à venir
un outil pédagogique quoi l'amour à dire
monde est toujours là tu histoire donc a
et b ou descendants d'esclaves et
beaucoup cette histoire pourrait être
mise à jour ou pas quand mes pièces
réseau de l'histoire des caves à genoux
en martinique
nous sommes très métissée à vendre des
abonnements comme en afrique parce que
moi j'ai basé commence au poulet - mais
ça après ma mort quelqu'un peut pas
encore moi pas en afrique aimés moissac
albi money jeunes africains - mon niveau
6 gènes indien le monde est jeune et
urbain et le blanc aussi quoi commencer
un jour le métier c'est que je le prends
comme un radis ça qui fait mon plaisir
c'est que la maternité n'est la savane
des esclaves à un certain moment la
maternité paix vous guettez paix parce
que martin génial même moment j'ai
carrément camille gamepad nageant mon
panier et mac a persisté d'un travail
acharné à faut des statuts voilà ce que
vous étiez b et l'aide commençaient
vraiment à la télé et vigala départ
n'est jamais inutile aux as well as tu
es déjà déjoué par rapport à travers un
riche programme autorise celle ratée de
la sava moment - belgique autant ça
avait conforté essabah - les forces pour
continuer pour un épi ben quoi parce
qu'elle aime encore travel encore la
matière on a au fleix encore la mater
mozilla mot chaotique à l allergie
macabre est aussi ses enfants snobé la
roma pourtant il est empilé village tard